good morning it's Tuesday a million
things are happening all at once first
and most importantly you are sick you
have shingles which is extremely painful
and it sucks and I'm sorry but I do feel
Hank that very little attention has been
paid to how your shingles affects the
literal center of the observable
universe at least when I'm observing it
me first off Hank because you were too
sick to make a video last week I was
deprived of four minutes of high quality
infotainment but also when you are sick
I feel sad and worried because you're so
great all right that's enough sentiment
on to the million things first I'm gonna
see a movie this week specifically I'm
gonna see the first cut of turtles all
the way down obviously there's a long
way to go before it comes out in
theaters or streaming or however movies
come out these days but I'm very excited
to see it in a little nervous I'll try
to make some John's channels videos
about it oh that reminds me there has
long been a Hank's Channel where Hank
makes Hank stuff but for the last
several months there has been a
semi-secret John's Channel where Jon
makes John's stuff I started the channel
as kind of an experiment like over some
months could I build an organic audience
for my shorter videos and the answer is
no like I made a video about
tuberculosis and toulouse-litrec that
got 17 views in two months so yeah I'm a
really good YouTuber whose success is
not at all dependent upon the fact that
I started in 2007 there is a link in the
two if we do to follow John's Channel if
you want also if you're wondering why I
look like an off-brand Rhett McLaughlin
it's because Pizza Miss is coming what
is pizza Miss it's two weeks every year
where we make week daily videos to sell
stuff with my mustache on it for charity
I can't really explain what pizza misses
only that pizza misses another thing you
know the actor Ryan Reynolds he and his
friend Rob have this amazing show right
now about buying and running wrexum AFC
a football club in Wales and uh this is
weird but I'm in the next episode
teaching a crash course about the
history of Wales the show is great you
don't even need to like football to
enjoy the show because it's not really
about football all it's about how
football of all the unimportant things
is the most important so yeah the show
is called Welcome to wrexum it stars
Ryan Reynolds Rob mcelhaney and a guy
whose personal YouTube channel has 167
subscribers two other things that are
happening one I'm quite busy writing at
the moment which is really nice one of
the many things I learned from Evan
pushak's great book Escape into meaning
is that writing is sort of the way I
have thoughts also I'm just having a lot
of fun writing I'd sort of forgotten
that writing can be enjoyable but it's
super fun finally as many of you know
our community is currently on track to
raise over 30 million dollars over the
first five years this decade to support
a stronger Healthcare System in Sierra
Leone's Kono District where one in 20
women will die in childbirth and where
one in 10 kids won't survive to the age
of five most of that money is going to
the building Staffing maintenance and
supplying of the maternal Center of
Excellence a teaching Hospital in the
Region's capital city of koidu but some
of it is going to support a stronger
Primary Health Care System especially in
the town of of kaima this Clinic is the
main source of medical care for over 90
000 people and it does not have reliable
running water or electricity but thanks
to your increased support the kaima
clinic is undergoing Renovations now and
increasing hiring and training to become
a safe space to deliver babies and
effectively refer more complicated cases
to the hospital and even more excitingly
all this progress has helped attract new
grants from Big foundations so that the
other Primary Health Care Clinics in
Kono can also see similar improvements
that has always been our hope that the
big funders in global Health would come
on board as they started to see progress
in Kono and that's starting to happen so
thank you thank you to all of our donors
at pih.org Hank and John thank you to
everybody who subscribes to the awesome
clubs and also to everyone who gives
their attention to this crisis and in
doing so supports those working to
address it Hank feel better I'll see you
on Friday